that we do have and we're going to start
with the race for governor two men very
familiar with each other will now face
each other in the general election
governor steve sislak easily won the
democratic nomination over former clark
county commissioner tom collins the
bigger news though is on the republican
side metro police sheriff joe lombardo
has won the gop nomination with 38
percent of the vote so far reno attorney
joey gilbert's in second place with 26
percent of the vote and former senator
dean heller finished in third sheriff
lombardo says he is pleased with his
performance
tonight is just a victory for our
campaign tonight is a win for nevada's
across the state
it's a win for parents and their
children's education
it's a win for a safer communities and
it's a win for small business owners
of course governor sysolak was on the
clark county commission they two know
each other very well and governor
sysolak has already gone on the attack
he says mr lombardo hasn't put nevada's
safety first and is just looking for
another promotion let the campaigns
begin well